let's return now to the greek prime
minister's meeting with Vladimir Putin
in Moscow it's led to some fears in
Brussels that Alexis tsipras government
is attempting to strengthen ties with
Russia while distancing itself from the
EU we spoke to the Russia analyst
William Pomerance of the Wilson Center
in Washington where Russia is trying to
do is find a way to separate grease from
the rest of the EU in least in terms of
its support for sanctions in order for
sanctions to be maintained on Russia
they all have to be renewed in June and
for that to take place there has to be
unanimity within the EU so clearly
Greece which is in it has its own
various difficulties with the EU is very
vulnerable and it also has traditional
trade with Russia that has been upset
because of the sanctions so what I think
Putin is trying to do is to pursue a
policy where he can divide the EU
potentially viagra sin other countries
and potentially and the sanctions
against Russia I think this is a very
tall order for Putin to pull off and
looking at the results of the meeting he
really didn't do it today uh they both
agreed that they didn't like sanctions
but Russia really didn't come forth with
any major offer of aid nor did Greece
evidently asked for that type of
assistance moreover Russia didn't even
end the sanctions on the import of
Russian of Greek food and meat products
which would have been a special
concession for lease instead Putin
essentially said that reaches a part of
the EU the Russian sanctions are against
the EU in total and therefore Greece
doesn't get any sort of concession visa
V the export of its products to Russia
Russia is in dire financial
circumstances and it is unlikely that it
could provide any real substitute
support for Greece which owes obviously
billions of dollars back to Germany and
two other EU countries Russia faces its
own financial crisis inflation is high
the price of oil is still down and
therefore Russia faces significant
budget deficits of its own indeed it
looks like it's going to have to pay
upwards of fifty billion dollars from
its own reserve funds just to balance
the budget in 2015 so Russia doesn't
have any money really to spare for
Greece all the money has to go to
support the Russian economy which as I
mentioned earlier is in very difficult
circumstances